[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est une vraie hécatombe depuis nos
premiers confinement la france fait face
à des licenciements en pagaille des
plans sociaux chez danone ibm total sans
compter ceux des plus petites
entreprises toutes les régions de france
sont touchées dans de très nombreux
secteurs mediapart des nombreux près de
75 mille emplois perdus au 2 décembre
dans plus de 300 entreprises selon le
magazine alternatives économiques c'est
carrément sept cent mille emplois
disparus depuis mars
mais bon on le sait tout ça c'est la
faute du coc vite pas besoin de
s'épancher sur la question voilà merci
de m'avoir écouté reid au générique de
ce trou enfin y'a peut-être pas quelques
vides non plus n'ont pourrait-on
soupçonner un effet d'aubaine ou un as
du 10 servie sur un plateau si vous
préférez mêmes et qu'ils avaient bornes
la ministre du travail à quelques
soupçons déclarant que des plans sociaux
en cette période poser question et
appelant notamment à la responsabilité
des grands groupes du cac 40
faut dire qu'avec les moyens mis sur la
table pour sauver les entreprises de la
crise pas le gouvernement un peu
l'impression d'être pris pour lapins de
six semaines
des milliards d'euros il attendait au
moins que les entreprises préservent
leurs salariés et fasse passer l'emploi
avant la rentabilité
c'est décidément mal connaître les
moustiques
danone par exemple 'l'annonce 2000
suppressions d'emplois dans le monde
mais maintient ses dividendes versés à
1,5 milliard d'euros ou total 1500
départs et 6 milliards d'euros sur
l'exercice de 2019 aux actionnaires de
là à penser qu'ils auraient favorisé les
actionnaires aux salariés et profiter du
coc vite pour mener à bien quelques
restructurations bien senti
prévue de longue date il n'y a qu'un pas
mais ce n'est pas moi qui ne franchirait